hello everyone round 5 of the World Cup
2017 in Tbilisi Georgia just finished
and all the games ended in a draw except
one encounter 11 Ariane vs. Vasily
Evangel
this game had quite a decisive result as
it ended in a miniature in 24 moves and
while Lebanon did have a pretty good
year he won pretty much every major
tournament he competed in last year was
also really good for Aragon and well
this was a real challenge for eventual
facing such a strong a 2800 Plus player
so let's see this game
lemon Ariane is playing with the white
pieces and even Chuck is black in this
game we have c4 e6 g g3 d5 and the
bishop to g2 so this is the English
opening and well does have a number of
options here he can go Knight to c6
Knight to f6 he can even even push d4
but if I'm shook decided to play D
captures on c4 we have Queen to a4
checked by our onion immediately going
for that c4 pawn we have c6 and the
Queen captures on c4 and if I should
place a b5 and this is a gaining space
on the Queen side the downside is that
while this powerful Bishop is now eyeing
this e6 pawn and there's a rockin AAA
behind it Queen c2 by Aragon and now
Bishop to b7 I will have nice to f3
Knight to d7 Knight to c3 and rope the
c8 we have castles by Aragon and we have
a six by von Schuch d4 and even to here
plays c5 and well if I took suspend
already ten moves developing his Queen
side and this does seem to solve the
problem of this light square bishop now
it's developed he managed to push c5
there's a rockin c8 everything seems
ideal but there's one problem his King
is still on a 8 and he hasn't developed
any of his King side pieces and of
course Aaron decides to take advantage
of this he plays d5 well the threat is d
captures on e6 and this would this would
be very annoying for black so we have
ich after sandy 5x1 choke and now
Knights to h4 he opens up the attack
from this bishop and g2 to this pawn on
d5
so if I defends this he plays Knight d2
f6 and here we have rook to d1 and well
he's attacking this he's attacking the
spawn three times now and well there is
no there's a little point in defending
it with tonight the e7 as this would
well your king is isn't going anywhere
from the middle of the board and Bishop
to g5 solves of all of White's problems
he will eliminate this knight on f6 and
this is much better for white
so after this rook to d1 idea you want
to play the g6 and here we have nice
capture son b5 we have night capture son
d5 and now e4 and of course this knight
is pinned now there's a rock on d1 we
have Bishop to g7 the magic is trying to
develop and get his King to safety he
captures on d5 we have Knight to f6 and
Queen to e2 check and Ireland doesn't
allow me one chip to castle as he did
leave his King in the middle of the
board a bit too long he reminds you
place came to f8 I think the f8 but King
37 isn't really possible trying to go
for the exchange of Queens because
simply Queen captures only 17 captures
any 7 and this d6 check move wins this
Bishop on b7 so after Queen to e to
check they want to played King to f8 and
we have a 4 iron on wants to break this
pawn structure if you want to spend ten
moves creating on the Queen side we have
b4 and Bishop to e3
now onion will focus his focuses pieces
and attacking this c5 pawn as it is a it
is a backwards a c5 pawn so we have
Queen 36 now defending this pawn we have
rook a to C 1 so this doesn't allow any
c4 IDs anymore
we have Knight to d7 adding more
protection to the c5 pawn and now well
onions pieces are all pretty much
ideally placed
this Bishop ng2 is very strong he's very
influential adding adding all the needed
protection to this d5 pawn both the
Roxxon are on idea ideal files the queen
is pretty good I need to there's only
this night on h4 not really doing
anything so the plan is pretty simple
this night is coming either to c4 or to
e4 depending on what event took place
so Knight to f3 we have h6 event which
is creating some breathing space for Ace
King
so he's preparing a maneuver like King
to g8 King to h7 and we'll try to get
his rook into the game and will somehow
castle artificially we have Knights to D
2 preparing either 94-94 and we have
King to g8 by vanship he really wants to
go to that h7 Square and now our even
plays Knight to e4 here he want to goes
Queen to f8 and well in this position
this is move 24 are in and played d6 and
it's in this position that event took
resigned the game and Arion played this
game extremely quickly in this position
Aragon was left with almost one full
hour and it's clock was 59 minutes and
some seconds and the event was done - I
believe it was 10 or 11 minutes so why
did the magic resign here well the
problem is how do you defend this c5
pawn the threat of course is Knight
captures on c5 and well you do have to
stop this somehow if you don't want to
give up give up this point you can you
can capture this knight on e4 but if you
play Bishop captures only 4 and the
Bishop captures on e4 now White has this
very annoying threat of Bishop to b7
attacking the rook and the spawn and a6
and this will create a very powerful
passed pawn on a4 so if something like a
5 is played to stop this again Bishop to
b7 is completely completely crushing as
well the rook has to move and after this
if the rook attacks the bishop here then
the bishop can move and attack the
knight and this will remove the defender
of the c5 pawn and if the rook moves
d8 for example then simply if rugby
Aiden simply capturing the bone
is winning for for white as these pawns
will soon follow and this is a very
strong pawn on d6 and after d6 black
can't really can't really defend the
dealer with Bishop to d4 trying to
defend this way as the knight captures
on c5 is again winning for white for
example if Bishop captures on c5 Bishop
captures on b7 and now this is what a
tempo in the rook after rook to e8 now
this Bishop on e3 is pinned Bishop
captures an a6 and the world now this
this best a pawn is beautiful so yeah
after this 24th move after iron and
played the d6 you might resign the game
and tomorrow Avenger will get his chance
for a rematch with the black pieces but
we've seen against kramnik that event
roof doesn't have a problem playing with
the black pieces against against the
2800 player so yeah and the one one
other interesting thing about this game
are in and managed to play the entire
game with the white pieces without
playing the move h4 so this is this is
well almost a novelty for him as h4 kind
of became his signature move so yeah
this is the game I do hope you enjoyed
it I will probably upload there
tomorrow's game as well so we'll see how
it goes
and yeah thank you for watching as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
and I will see you soon